- Okay, thanks for being here
and singing your song,
Ain't Goin' Down Till
the Sun Comes up With Me.
I was very nervous about it
because it's a wordy song, man.
- There's a lot of words there.
- It's a wordy song,
I might have messed up a couple times,
it's all right we're singing loud, people.
Everyday I do sing a song requested
by someone in my studio audience.
So, are you ready to find
out who requested your song?
- Oh, I would love to.
- Okay, all right.
So, where is Devon?
(crowd clapping)
There's Devon, hi!
- Hello, Miss Devon.
- Hi, Garth.
Hi, Kelly.
- So tell us Devon,
why did you request that specific song?
- Yeah, since that songs
older than you are.
(crowd laughing)
- It might be but I've been listening-
- [Kelly] Classic music last, Garth.
- I've been listening to you,
Garth since I was in infant
and actually, funny
connection to that song
is that about three years ago,
I met my now husband,
and our parents knew each other,
and so we connected instantly.
But then that week we
were texting all the time
and that Sunday he invited me
on our first date to the LA Zoo.
And of course he had a truck,
so I thought, fitting,
let me put this song on.
So, I went ahead and I put the song on
and I serenaded him down to the zoo.
And he was so impressed I knew every word
to that song.
He says-
- I'm impressed you know
every word to that song.
- Atta, girl.
- So he says its my super power
and here we are married four months and I-
- Good for you!
- Oh my gosh, good for you!
(crowd clapping)
- All right, well I've got no doubt,
a lot of you in the
audience love Garth's music,
if you don't, you're dumb.
(crowd laughing)
- Because it's like literally
the greatest catalog ever of music.
I can't even believe your career,
I'm so jealous.
I mean, I'm so happy for you.
(crowd laughing)
I'm just kidding.
It's so heartfelt,
it's so inspired.
It's just so, so good.
Where are Wes and Katie at?
Are Wes and Katie-
Oh, hi!
(crowd clapping)
Oh, I'm sorry is she okay?
Hi, love!
- We're all good,
we're good, we're good.
- Oh, I'm so sorry
So, hey you guys have
a connection to Garth
- I know you!
- [Wes] We do.
- We have a slight connection,
we actually
- [Garth] I know you,
but where do I know you from?
- We went to your
concert in summer of 2017
and we made a sign at one of your concerts
and you called us up to the front.
And our sign said,
working on a full house, boy or girl?
- Oh, the gender reveal!
- And you did our gender reveal.
- This is her!
- Yes.
- Is that Brooks?
- This is baby Brooks.
- [Kelly] Oh, my gosh.
(crowd clapping)
- You named her Brooks!
- That is awesome.
She is so sweet,
congratulations.
- Thank you.
- Thank you, it is a pleasure.
She is beautiful.
- [Kelly] Oh, my gosh!
- [Garth] That's so sweet.
- Unfortunately, we scared Brooks
with our song earlier,
- You were just finding out
it was a lot for Brooks.
- Yeah they were just finding out,
well she just found out she was pregnant.
And so there's a sign
back there that says,
two of a kind, working on a full house,
which we had already
played earlier in the show.
- Played at the beginning, yeah.
- So I'm sitting there, but I'm going,
why in the world is he still holding it up
and then they had this
envelope or something with it.
- All right, the moment Garth revealed,
I didn't want to interrupt him,
I liked the story.
- You got this.
- The moment-
- You're going to love this
- Garth revealed the gender
of Wes and Katie's baby,
was captured on camera,
check this out!
- Do we have names yet?
- Brooks!
- Brooks.
(crowd cheering)
- I love this, this is going to be good.
So, if it's a boy it's a Brooks,
if it's a girl it's a Brooks, right?
Right, that's what you're saying?
- [Audience Member] Wait,
come back over here,
come back over here.
- I got to tell you,
I'm extremely happy for you
because I have three of these.
(crowd cheering)
- [Garth] That was good,
that was good.
- That was amazing!
Thank you so much for sharing your story!
Oh, my gosh, all right.
Where is Chris?
Where's Chris at?
Oh, hi!
You have a bow tie on,
you cute thing, okay.
- Oh, thank you.
So why does Garth's music
mean so much to you?
- I first became a fan when I was 14,
I saw you in concert.
Actually went with some people
and I've seen you about a dozen,
more than a dozen times now.
- Oh, man thank you.
- Yeah, so my very first concert,
and actually my last
concert that I saw was you.
Your songs just have helped
me throughout my life,
there was a time in my
life where I felt stuck.
I was in a dead end job,
with an overbearing manager,
and it was affecting my
relationship at work,
and everybody else.
And I just, was not a
good person to be with
and I remember,
going to your benefits concert in 2007,
for the fires.
- Yeah, for the Southern
California wildfire.
- And I just remember you sang the River,
and I just started crying.
- Oh, my gosh.
(Garth laughs)
Like I've already been holding it back,
let's just hug it out,
let's just hug it out.
Oh my good.
(crowd cheering)
Go ahead, go ahead.
- So that song just moved me
to quit that job,
and get out of California all together.
I moved to a different state,
put myself in a good place
and ever since then,
that song just has been a catalyst
for change for me.
- Very sweet.
- Yeah and right now I'm
kind of going through
that same moment, so.
- That's amazing.
- That's very sweet.
- Isn't music powerful?
- It is.
- Music is like that for me.
That was, I had to hug him because...
- Thank you, pal
I appreciate that.
- [Kelly] I was about to cry with him
- Thank you.
- Oh, my gosh.
Thank you so much, Chris
- I want to come here everyday
- I know you have to hug him,
- This is awesome.
- That was beautiful.
And it is such a great song,
and a name for a child,
I'm just saying, River.
It's my little girl's
name if you didn't know.
We're just naming all our
kids after your music.
- Thank you.
- People love meeting you,
I mean, I know this
because I'm one of them.
But have you ever just
completely lost your mind
and like, goofed out
over one of your idols?
- Oh, all the time.
- Yeah.
- Every time Trisha Yearwood
walks through that door.
- Oh, good answer.
Good answer.
She is the greatest vocalist.
You know I'm a nerd for her.
- Thank you.
- Her voice is like the sound of crystal.
- Well the crazy thing is too,
awards are only as good
as the people's names
that are on them.
Compliments are only as good
as the people that give them.
- Oh, you're nice!
You're nice.
- You're a freak.
(crowd laughing)
You're a freak of nature and everybody
in the business knows it.
You have no ceiling,
so for you to say that about her,
she would sit here and say the
same exact thing about you.
- She's the one I'd be
singing with the hairbrush.
- She loves you, man.
- So who do you freak out over?
- George Strait because you know,
I've always wanted to be George Strait.
I noticed you had a picture of him up in
the dressing room back there.
James Taylor.
- Yeah he's one in the dressing room,
- James Taylor,
he was supposed to be at a thing,
we were doing a thing for the Christmas
at the White House and he's not there.
It's freezing outside playing,
everybody's wondering where James is.
But James is just there,
he's just not on location.
So I start playing the song
that we're going to sing,
and the next thing I knew,
he comes up and I hear his voice.
But the problem is,
now fat boy slim is playing
James Taylor's guitar.
(crowd laughing)
- That's a little nerve wracking.
- And James is looking at you,
and you're like everything just
becomes one bone all of a sudden.
You're like, I don't even
know if I can play this.
And he was always so sweet, man.
- He's the nicest .
- He is, good man.
But you know what I found out?
The coolest ones and
the biggest superstars
are always the sweetest.
- Amen, Dolly's like that.
Dolly's one of my favorites.
(crowd cheering)
- Dolly.
- Reba.
they're just..
- They're all good girls.
- Yeah they're like who you think
they're going to be.